[Music]
hey everybody uh yep I'm Kyle Corbett
from open pipe and I'm here with Mustafa
Ali from method we're going to be
talking about how method has scaled in
production to over 500 million agents uh
and basically all the the tricks they
use to make that actually work so a
little bit about method is that we
essentially collect and centralize
liability data from across hundreds of
different data sources this includes
tapping into the credit bureaus uh
connecting with the card networks like
visa and MasterCard um and just direct
connections with the financial
institutions and various other third
party sources and you know we uh sort of
aggregate and enhance this data and
serve it to our customers who are
typically other fintechs Banks or
lenders and they use this enhanced data
to um anything really to do with debt
management so refinancing loan
consolidation liability payments or just
Personal Finance Management
um yeah and at open pipe what we do is
we help you build uh train and deploy
open source models um for actual usage
we also let you use in production your
signals you get from users from the
environment to improve your model
continuously over time and that's some
of the things we'll be talking about uh
what we did with method nice
so one of the early challenges that we
faced at method while coming up with
this you know aggregation pipeline uh
was that some of our customers basically
came to us and said you know it's really
nice that you can give us the balance
and payment information on a specific
liability for their end consumers but
you know what would be really nice is if
you could also give us some of these
liability specific data points like the
payoff amount on an auto loan or the
escrow balance for a mortgage and you
know we said okay let's do some research
so we go back to to some of our data
partners and basically ask them you know
is there anything you know we can plug
into to get these kinds of data points
and what we found was there's really no
Central API that we could get access to
that would allow us to get some of these
data points and of course ideally we
would want to work with uh directly with
the banks but you know having already
worked with banks before and just from
initial conversations we realized that
it would easily take up to at least a
couple of years before getting anything
solid done and you know we we're an
early stage company so we want to build
for the customer fast um and so that's
really what we're trying to come up with
a solution that we can just you know uh
push into production
tomorrow and so just to get better
understanding of how some of these
companies are operating today uh the
services that they're providing today
how are they doing that in the first
place right like they must be getting
that data somehow so we go back to some
of these customers and basically ask
them you know how are you guys operating
and what they tell us is is kind of
interesting so a lot of these companies
they basically hire offshore teams of
contractors and you know they uh these
teams are basically responsible for
calling these Banks um on behalf of the
company and the end consumer they
authenticate with the banks gather the
necessary information somebody has to
proof check it it gets sent back um and
then it gets integrated into the
financial platforms um and it get surfac
to the user is used for underwriting
stuff like that and so that's the status
quo that we're dealing with here and
when you think about it that's a very
inefficient manual process right it's
it's when you try to think about scaling
it does doesn't really scale it's a very
um it has a lot of problems you know
it's expensive because one person can
only do one thing at a time right so if
you want to scale uh you basically have
to hire more people and for the same
reason because it's so synchronous it's
also really slow um and the main I guess
the the biggest problem with that is
also that it's there's a lot of human
error involved and um you you need to
hire a team to fact check it uh to proof
check it and um it's the the the the
worst thing that you can end up with is
to surface basically inaccurate
financial
information and so conceptually though
if you think about it it's kind of like
an API right you have the request
component you have the authentication
component you have the response
validation all that stuff uh so
essentially when you drill this problem
down into the core problem that's really
just trying to make sense of um
unstructured data right so if only there
was this magic tool or software that we
could use that was really good at
parsing unstructured
data and and you know lucky for us
around the time that we were trying to
solve this problem open aai announced
gbd4 and you know as people like to call
it there was this Cambrian explosion of
AI or llm enabled applications all
around us and the results were just
mind-blowing um and we thought to
ourselves you know this this this is the
perfect thing for us this is like a
godsend uh so we tried to like you know
we tried to see if there's anything
there that we could use and if there's
one thing that we all know in this room
is that advanced llms especially post
gbd4 are really good with um with
parsing unstructured data so tasks like
summarization or classification they're
really good with that kind of thing so
we want to test that theory out and see
what that can get
us and so we put our heads down hack
together this agentic workflow using GPD
4 and as expected you know it worked
really well so we tried to like expand
some of our use cases because you know
the API costs are high so we wanted to
get as much as we could from a single
API call and you know it turned out to
be really good at that so we tried to
obviously this was in a very controlled
manner um but this was in production and
so we were testing out uh different uh
extractions basically and um you know
everything was going really good uh but
as soon as we started to increase a
little bit of uh traffic uh what we
found was you know the bill had to come
do and um it was a lot so $70,000 for
our first month in production with gbd4
and you know this was this made
leadership really unhappy and you know
but um but it was something it was
something they were they were fine with
because the value that we were getting
out of gp4 was so immense um and so we
actually kept this thing in production
for at least a couple more months as we
tried to work around this kind of cost
problem and you know cost wasn't the
only thing that we were concerned with
um as we started to scale some of these
use cases we quickly ran into a wall
with prompt engineering it only takes
you so far um one thing we realized that
even though gbd is really smart it's not
a financial expert so you had to give it
really detailed instructions and
examples uh to really make it work with
all kinds of use cases that we were
trying to Target um so it's hard to
generalize those kinds of prompts they
become really long convoluted it's
always a cat and mouse Chase with you
fix it for a certain scenario and it
breaks for another one you fix it for
that one it breaks for the previous one
and so you're all this going back and
forth we didn't have any prompt
versioning so we had to figure out a
better way to make this work for all of
our use cases
and so the tldr here is that you know we
we didn't want to adopt that initial
solution that I just talked about
earlier in the slides because of its
scaling challenges and just because it
was so inefficient but we kind of ran
into the same scaling challenges with
GPT where it was expensive because we
couldn't really optimize for caching
because of the variability and responses
and the prompt tweaks we were making all
the time and the Baseline latency that
we were finding was actually really slow
so we couldn't you know it was overall
we couldn't scale concurrently and
similar to human errors that were kind
of uh in a different nature we had AI
errors which were just hallucinations
that were hard to catch um and we just
couldn't scale with this kind of system
but we still kept it in production
because for a specific use cases was
actually really really
good and so now the problem shifted from
solving that core problem of trying to
make sense of unstructured data that was
solved with GPT now the problem shifted
to how do we scale this system how do we
build
a robust uh you know agentic workflow
that can handle this kind of volume
reliably and so some of the ballpark
figures that we came up with you know is
that we we're going to be at least
making 16 million requests per day uh
we're going to have at least 100K
concurrent load and you know we need
minimal latency to um handle this kind
of real-time agentic workflow so sub 200
milliseconds and you know so the natural
next step for us was like we thought to
ourselves do we buy more gpus do we host
our own model like what do we do at this
point
um so that at that point open pipe comes
in yeah so about a year ago we started
working with method on solving these
issues that Mustafa just listed and we
actually found that the those three
issues he listed right which are quality
cost um and latency are very common um
these are things that you know across
almost everyone we work with uh at least
some subset of those are really top of
mind um and so with uh method
specifically we were working on okay how
do we how do we solve those problems in
a way that that makes this uh you know a
viable business for you so uh the first
thing we did was start measuring error
rates um you know like like he mentioned
uh even AI models are not perfect uh
these are all probabilistic systems
getting to a 0% error rate was not
really feasible but we were able to see
different models had different uh had
different performance characteristics
there so on Modern models on the task
they're doing these are the rates we're
seeing on gbd4 um we're at about an 11%
error rate uh and with 03 mini it's much
better it's a 4% error rate um the way
you measure that is going to be specific
to your business and that that's
actually true to some extent for all
three of these things we'll talk about
uh in the case of method this is
actually relatively easy to measure
luckily because they have this agentic
workflow but like ultimately what the
agent is trying to do is is fill out um
you know extract all this information he
was talking about Bank balances things
like that and so you can you can have a
human go through the flow and figure out
what the real number should be and then
you can compare an agentic systems final
outputs to that and see if it was
successful or not
um which which made this part relatively
easy to calculate uh so these are kind
of the error rates we're getting um on
the latency point of view uh we see that
gp40 is around a second uh to respond uh
and then o03 mini takes about 5 seconds
for their specific task again this is
somewhat task dependent uh depending on
how much you know for example O3 has to
think as you're measuring this you also
want to make sure that you're using real
production conditions that you're
actually doing um you know like a real
diversity of tasks uh that that match
what you're actually doing and at a
reasonable and currency level that
matches your production um and we also
measured the cost um so again cost uh
this is something that is going to
obviously be specific and how much it
matters is also very specific to your
use case as well um interestingly 03
mini even though it has a much lower per
token cost than GPD 40 if you just look
at like the pricing page on the API for
their specific use case uh we found it
was a little bit more expensive because
it has it generates many more reasoning
tokens so it has much longer outputs um
again though this is somewhat Tas
dependent so I just recommend
um actually just just as an aside I
would recommend once you get to the
point that you're trying to optimize
that you have sort of that initial proof
of concept with with some model
something that works I think it's really
worthwhile to it can be as simple as
like literally just writing like you
know three different Python scripts that
like are able to categorize each of
these for a different model um and then
as new models come out you'll be able to
quickly tell how they're doing um okay
once you've done or in this case once
we've done this this sort of um
benchmarking of where the models are
next question is all right what is where
do we need these models to be where do
we need to get to um and so again this
is very task dependent uh in the case of
method uh they do have special like they
have um extra checks that happen after
this where they look and see okay are
the numbers that came out plausible do
they match you know the types of things
we're seeing before all the all these
different kinds of checks they're doing
and so they didn't need to get all the
way down to a 0% error rate but of
course those checks are still followable
and so um if it's over a certain point
then then some fraction of those errors
are going to get through and that's
going to be bad so we found around a 9%
error rate was was able to get them what
they needed um from a latency point of
view so the way their agent works is a
realtime system uh it it needs to be
able to respond quickly to to move uh
through the the basically like through
the whole flow to get the information it
needs and so they did have a hard
latency cut off um we see a wide variety
in this for what it's worth we have some
customers that I talked to who it's like
hey if I get a result back at some point
in the next few days like that's totally
fine this is a background bash process
um we have other customers who are doing
real-time voice with the human on the
other end of the line and it's like hey
you know if I'm over 500 milliseconds
that's not going to work for me and so
again you just have to know for your
specific case how much this matters same
with cost um in their case because of
that very high volume as mustaf was
mentioning cost is pretty important to
them um again depending on your use case
usually mostly dependent on how high
volume it is um will determine how much
cost matters to you but but it's
something you you you should know these
numbers for your specific task as you're
comparing different models okay so um
we're looking here at this uh of course
as you're looking at this this slide you
can you may see there's a problem here
which is um of the two models we're
comparing at least none of them actually
meet all three of the requirements we
need to be able to deploy this in
production and uh you know gbd4 on both
the error rate as well as the cost we're
not quite there um and then 03 mini uh
on the cost but especially on the
latency it's just not going to work for
what we need so this is the point at
which uh method came and they talked to
us we're like hey we're not able to hit
what we need here um because again we're
not uh yeah we're these these models
aren't getting us where we need to be so
what we work on in open pipe is fine
tuning we work on building custom models
for your specific use case and so I'm
going to talk about why you would want
to do that and how that helps in this
case um first I would say fine-tuning is
a power tool uh it does take more time
it takes more um engineering investment
than just prompting a model uh so you
don't really want to do that until you
have actually benchmarked the production
models just prompting them and seen
whether they work or not um so in this
case in meth's case and and in all of
our customers cases uh they found that
they were not able to hit the numbers
they needed um and so that's the time
you want to bring in fine
tuning um so let's look at we were able
to find tuna model and see uh how that
was able to help uh because it can
actually really bend that price
performance curve a lot um so on the the
error rate uh which is basically just
the inverse of of accuracy if you want
to measure it that way um we were able
to get to a place where we were doing
significantly better than GPD 4 and
importantly better than that threshold
they needed uh this used to actually be
much harder to achieve it required a lot
of manual uh labeling of data and things
like that it's actually become much
easier over time because of the
existence of models like now o03 mini um
which allows you to just use your
production data you can you can use your
uh basically the inputs you're using
production you can uh generate outputs
for them using a model like O3 mini and
train on them we find like in this case
that often you're not able to quite get
uh to the the performance of the the
teacher model the model o03 mini in this
case that you're using but you can get
quite close to it and usually do much
better than you know uh a slightly less
good but much much larger model um you
know in this case uh the model we ended
up deploying with them is just an 8
billion parameter LL 3.1 model and and
we find that actually for the majority
of our customers a model that large or
smaller is is good enough and is able to
hit the numbers you need from quality um
but uh yeah the important thing is to be
able to Benchmark that and to answer
that question for yourself
um on the latency point of view because
actually this this is sort of the magic
of being able to move to that much
smaller model because we've got this AP
billion parameter model it is way easier
to deploy in a low latency way um
there's just many few fewer calculations
for your sequential calculations with
the number of layers and so you can get
just a much lower latency you can even
and we we didn't actually have to do
this in method's case but something you
can do is you can train this model you
can deploy it within your own
infrastructure collocate it with the
application code that's using it um and
even completely eliminate the the
network
latency uh and then finally uh on the
cost front again just because this is
such a smaller model um you end up with
a much much lower cost uh and so that
for many of our customers is a big is
incredibly important is to be able to
get that performance number you need um
while still maintaining a relatively low
cost um in in method's case we were
actually able to far exceed the sort of
cost thresholds that they were looking
for to make this viable um which means
that they don't have to worry about this
from sort of a unit economics point of
view uh in in in the way that they did
when they were using the larger
models um so just um to sort of
reiterate what I started with before um
this is a power tool uh the fine tuning
uh is it does take a fair amount of work
um not an extreme amount of work but
significantly more work than you do for
prompt
engineering however if you're not able
to get to the reliability numbers you
need uh through just prompt engineering
with the models that exist out there
without tuning it is a viable way to
very strong bend that price performance
curve and get to a much better place uh
which uh which which can help you get to
a very large scale in production just
like method
did nice um so yeah just to wrap up here
uh one thing that or at least a couple
couple points that we want to highlight
is that you know the reason we put two
engineers in the title is also because
it's not that it's not that complicated
right you can get away with using we
identified a specific use case and we
got away with just using the cheapest
model that was out there uh we
fine-tuned it we already had the data
from GPT in production so we already had
the data we didn't have to go digging
around for the data in the first place
uh so we already used that and we used
the cheapest model that gave us the
fastest performance and you know you
don't need to buy your own gpus um and
the the other thing that we realize is
that productionizing AI agents actually
requires a little bit of uh some level
of openness uh and patience from the
engineering team from the leadership
team is because when you write code
we're all used to writing code that just
work works you push out a feature and
never breaks because you're not changing
anything but with AI agents you it takes
some time to get to a point where it's
like production ready and actually gives
you the responses that you're looking
for um and you know I I feel compelled
to say something about as to Mark the
top of the traditional software
engineering job so I'll leave you with
these last few words if you're Inu pivot
to
AE thank you thanks everyone
[Music]